polizei hautnah wenn albträume zur
realität werden dann ist die polizei zur
stelle und wie schwer ihre arbeit ist
das konnte jetzt unsere kollegin
angelique er selber mit eigenen augen
sehen denn sie hat die polizei begleitet
um zu sehen was an tatorten passiert
wenn es da wirklich zum äußersten
gekommen ist
sie sind die männer für die besonders
schweren fälle
[Musik]
die kommissare silvan bormann und till
flat vom kriminaldauerdienst in hannover
wenn der verdacht einer straftat besteht
sind die beamten von kdd die ersten vor
ort was sie erwartet wissen sie nie
feierabend haben sie erst wenn der job
getan ist montag dienstbeginn die woche
startet mit einem tragischen einsatz
ein arbeitsunfall auf einer baustelle
nur fünf kilometer von der wache
entfernt
das todesopfer ist noch nicht geborgen
[Musik]
gefallen ist jetzt leider verstorben
unsere aufgabe besteht jetzt darin dass
wir mit den zeugen des vorfalls sprechen
und dann einen objektiven gefunden haben
dass wir beschreiben die gegebenheiten
machen eine kriminalpolizeiliche solange
die todesursache noch nicht eindeutig
geklärt ist muss polizeioberkommissar
bormann allen hinweisen nachgehen
die arbeiter auf der baustelle stehen
unter schock
vor wenigen minuten ist einer von ihnen
ums leben gekommen was ist hier passiert
besonders tragisch der tote ist erst 20
jahre alt ein schlosser geselle acht
meter ist er in die tiefe gestürzt und
vermutlich mit dem kopf auf den beton
geschlagen seine kollegen leisteten noch
erste hilfe
vergeblich wir haben das hier unter
seinen kopf gelegt und dann haben die
das darum und da haben wir ja schon
gemerkt dass sie ganz recht heft und der
der war sofort tot
das ist einfach so gar nichts mehr hat
der junge mann das gleichgewicht
verloren warum war er auf der
arbeitsbühne nicht gesichert
polizeioberkommissar der ruf litt
befragt die anderen bauarbeiter wer hat
schuld
nach der aufnahme des möglichen tatorts
muss silvan bormann die gesetzlich
vorgeschriebene leichenschau durchführen
also wenn ich jetzt sagen will dass ihr
das nichts ausmachen würde ich glaube
ich lügen das geht natürlich einem
schuldner auch wenn das jemand ist der
sehr junges oder im gleichen alter ist
nichtsdestotrotz gehört zum job dazu und
kommen die man muss hier machen
wenn ich feierabend habe der markt hat
und dann habe ich feierabend und
freizeit und dann geht es erst wieder
los wenn ich zum dienst kommen
und uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt zum
eu-kommissar silbern borrmann hallo herr
baumann hallo ja in ihrem job da ist man
täglich mit sehr viel leid und ganz
besonderen schicksalen konfrontiert wie
ertragen sie das es ist dann die routine
die sich im lauf der jahre entwickelt
hat und die einen die sicherheit in den
einsätzen gibt und natürlich dann auch
die einsätze die wir dort tagtäglich
erleben ertragen ist können sie uns
einmal etwas genauer erklären was der
kriminaldauerdienst genau macht wie als
kriminaldauerdienst sind sozusagen die
feuerwehr der kriminalpolizei die sind
immer die ersten am tatort das heißt
wenn es um todesermittlungen geht um
brand ermittlungen geht um sexualdelikte
oder andere verbrechen tatbestände sind
wie immer die ersten die dann vor ort
sind die tatortaufnahme machen und für
die spurensuche und die spurensicherung
kann wirklich sind
gibt es da auch einen fall an den sie
sich jetzt noch erinnern ihr leben lang
wahrscheinlich sogar erinnern werden
tatsächlich gibt es einige einsetzen die
man noch mal zurück denkt tragisch sind
immer die einsätze die kinder
jugendliche betreffen oder personen im
gleichen alter
wenn ich jetzt mal konkret zurück denke
denke ich an einem 15 jährigen der auf
grund schlechter schulnoten sich das
leben genommen hat und das ist auch
etwas was man nicht nach dienstschluss
dann vergisst sondern damit beschäftigt
man sich auch noch tage oder wochen
danach ja das ist mehr als verständlich
sie sehen im jahr etwa 100 tote an
verschiedenen tatorten kann man da
überhaupt in irgendeiner art und weise
mit der zeit ein bisschen abstumpfen
tatsächlich ist es so dass man abstumpft
ich beschreibe das immer ganz gerne als
einen moment wenn ich zu einer leiche
gerufen werde dass ich nach einer zeit
weiß was mich erwartet
es gibt neue kollegen für die sind erst
mal sämtliche tatort etwas besonderes
natürlich und auch aus ganz
schreckliches wenn man so etwas noch nie
gesehen hat aber ab einem gewissen
zeitpunkt im dienst weiß man was einen
erwartet und man kann sich darauf
einstellen und das stimmt dann ein stück
weit auf also routine tritt natürlich
nicht ein aber man erträgt es sicherlich
mit der zeit etwas leichter herr baumann
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch gerne mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren